now i'm in the center of
ukraine
capital kiev i wouldn't
wish
for no one
to feel what we feel now it's a pain
it's uh
anger it's the fear it's the courage
it's everything it's
there should be a word for this as i'm
volunteering we deliver food we deliver
uh mad thing
and uh you cannot imagine how many how
many people are in need today i had only
uh six volunteers
uh helping me out with the three cars we
delivered 25
portions of uh
packed food
to old people who are alone i can't
describe you
their eyes and they're like saying thank
you we deliver
the drugs medicine to
to women with children who are
ill who are after cancer and then people
started to ask me for
okay can you do this can you do this and
i was yes i will do this because as long
as i'm here
i will never stand and watch
i will help the whole city is
is prepared
to to give a fight i don't want to i
don't want to do this
i mean
why
but if somebody will threaten
my independence
if somebody will threaten
my people yes i'm ready to take a gun
and to protect not to kill but to
protect this is a difference between us
they're
trying to invade and they're killing our
women they're killing our children they
are killing civilians they are
destroying our infrastructure how would
people from moscow feel
if they would be bombarded
they would run away because they're
co-words and bastards not all of them
not all of them but they can stop it
they can stop it they told me oh what
should we do what should you do go on
the streets our people are
stopping tanks with their bodies because
they're done afraid of it and and moscow
people or or russian people they're
afraid to be beaten whatever we are not
we are not afraid
we are not afraid
and i told to myself you know the first
thing was on my mind yes yes to run to
run and hide
but you know you can run but you never
will escape yourself and i thought to
myself who am i if i'm gonna leave
these people we need your help we need
we need the help of every single person
in the world
to send us uh
funds to send us weapons uh we will we
will fight back and if you can send
troops and us troops
nato should close the sky
and uh
everybody should know that the the world
has started the third world war and
we we all have to stop it
not just us but we all are in danger
and uh i hope that uh
one day
all of you will come to ukraine and
we'll see
how beautiful
are our people how beautiful is our
capital and how beautiful is everything
about this country
you